these streets should be teeming with
people they aren't they've been
abandoned because of the gang violence
particularly against women and children
homes and businesses schools and
nurseries left empty but even in this
wasteland the gangs are totally in
control ruthlessly in control I'll guide
all in talks and I'm constantly on the
phone the door open so they can see us
every inch of territory is fought over
every day so give you some perspective
of just to know how dangerous this area
is but this is a burial 18 which is one
of the gangs and the police regularly
here were told by the locals because
they're trying to keep the line because
where that wall says burial that road
beyond it is the gang called ms-13 these
two gangs but basically wants together
but now they're absolute enemies
so in this often abandoned area now is
hardly anyone living here this is the
dividing line and if you came out of
this area and cross over there and they
didn't know you they'd kill you and see
over there that's 13 written on the wall
we'd been here for just five minutes
when we got news of another murder this
shop owner was shot dead in broad
daylight because he wouldn't pay the
gangs extortion those are the rules
and everyone knows this woman was in
charge of extortion her gang has allowed
her to retire to look after her mother
we can't identify her
because even speaking to us carries a
death sentence but she spoke because she
wants people to know what's happening
here what happened to the people if you
do if they don't pay the extortion we
give them a time frame to pay then a
warning and if they don't pay then the
members will kill them do you think
you'll ever join the gang again no if
you did try to join and try to leave
what would happen they would kill me the
sheer number of killings on a daily
basis here is quite extraordinary we
know for certain of at least three
murders every night we stayed those are
just the murders we can guarantee happy
negotiating your way through the
gangland is crazily dangerous not least
because the boundaries aren't even a
street apart
this is ms-13 territory
this is now barrio 18 territory
and now this is the territory of the
avocado gang silly name
but the avocados killed eleven last week
one continuous theme running through all
of this is the disproportionate number
of women being killed
it's why so many families are leaving
but for some the gangs offer a solution
to the failure of the state to protect
people
these brothers witnessed the murder of
their mother and two sisters when 25 men
broke into their house it was even big
news here at the time the boy on the
right has joined earnest 13 and he did
so to exact revenge every one of the 25
who were involved has been killed the
families females were killed because one
of the girls said no to a gang member
they wound up on Kuna Yala purana
sequestering LaMotta / SLO deo pio Sarah
Champa Matar bill re sequester are
ordinary tophi by manner and a casa
playa no Holly I'm Adela to DiPaola
cotta P como que le gusta el gouna
Ladakh way ba mocha no Korean knock on a
your pooja will carry on my own that way
going on man Alejo
for many in the worst areas of the
so-called northern triangle of Central
America there are very few good options
left stay and accept life under the
gangs or head north to the United States
and try to find sanctuary but you must
choose if you do nothing somebody in
your family will die it's likely to be a
female
still Ramsay Sky News Honduras